- [Announcer] This satellite
image shows a convoy
of more than 20 vehicles linked
to the Wagner mercenary group entering
the cell military base in Belarus.
Here on July 17,
hundreds of tents and
facilities fill the camp.
32 days earlier, none of this was here.
The growth of the base
signals that the private army
is relocating large numbers
of personnel and equipment.
That's following the
deal brokered by Belarus
that curtailed the group's
June 24 drive towards Moscow
to demand the removal of
Russia's military leadership.
So here's how the campers expanded
and the likely route the
vehicles linked to Wagner took
following the group's aborted mutiny.
A video posted by a pro-Russia
war correspondent in mid-July
shows a convoy of trucks
and cars heading north
on the M-4 highway in Russia.
Another clip shared by the
same account shows vehicles
driving approximately 73
miles north on the same road.
Some of them can be seen with Wagner flags
hanging out of the windows.
Across the border in Belarus,
this video captures yet another
convoy of similar vehicles
a 15-minute drive away from the cell camp.
Military analysts say satellite
imagery shows vehicles
of the same make and
color exiting the highway
and entering the base.
The vehicles seen in these
videos and images likely traveled
through Russia into
Belarus along this route.
That's based on data from Janes,
a group which has been
tracking Wagner's movements
using social media video
and additional clips
geo located by Storyful.
Janes said it tracked
at least 260 vehicles
in separate convoys between
the 11th and 18th of July.
Images from the following
week showed dozens
of pickup trucks, minivans,
cars and heavy lift trailers
parked at the facility.
Analysts say their characteristics
match what was seen
in the social media videos,
and the timing of their arrival indicates
they were from Wagner-linked convoys.
The movements are the
largest public showing linked
to the mercenary group since
the failed march on Moscow.
Military analysts say it
could indicate preparations
for the arrival of a large group
of equipment and personnel.
The previously vacant facility
is also being adjusted
to be more habitable.
Smoke or steam is being emitted
from a stack in these images,
analysts from Janes say,
suggesting it's being used
for electrical generation or heating.
In addition, a vehicle position
next to the communication
tower in this image
indicates that he's being ready for use.
Analysts say there are
limited other reasons
why a vehicle would
need to be parked there.
Living facilities have also been built
potentially indicating plans
for a more permanent presence at the base.
Analysts at Janes and Maxar
said latrines have been placed
along the outer perimeter of
the tent deployment areas,
and rows of outdoor
sinks are also present.
The expansion of the camp
comes amid speculation
over Wagner's next moves.
The whereabouts of the group's
leader, Yevgeny Prigozhin,
have been in question
since the failed mutiny.
This social media footage
which has been geo
located to the cell base
purportedly shows the Wagner
leader welcoming troops.
(Yevgeny speaking in foreign language)
(troops speaking in foreign language)
While military analysts
say it's still unclear what
the expansion of the cell camp
ultimately means for Wagner,
this location may play a key
role in the group's future.
(pensive music)